la scritta scoreggia nucleare
[Risate]
oggi proveremo varie opzioni c'è
proveremo a fare delle foto ma se
sbagliamo gli ingredienti ci
trasformiamo anche strane o si guarda là
dietro sul gioco alcuni che ha sbagliato
una posizione vicina
pertanto lasciatemi vivere
10 mila mi piace stare anche un altro
episodio delle pozioni magari proviamo a
fare degli incantesimi
siano aiuto loro non arrivano qua e là
allora cerchiamo di capire cosa dobbiamo
fare quello che vanno
da fermo di vaio può essere anche tu
dove sei scappato
ecco allora che il nostro libro degli
ingredienti in vista ed è stato calato
interlocuzione perino qua ho fatto
diventare penati quella specie di
fiammella che succede in questo allora
proprio per questa pozione magari
insomma pratica però c'è un marino qui
aspetta come si fa a prendere questo
questo bastoncino a metterlo nel
calderone ok ora dice di mescolare la
pozione vediamo
ecco la guarda musica nomi a bozzone tv
di dubbio nel frattempo laggiù la rara
farne gamble
ma prova a bere la pozione vediamo cosa
succede
[Musica]
dove si chiare
come faccio a tornare normale sono
diventata un motto non funziona anno
devo provare qualche altro ingrediente
vediamo dice strand which ammuffito
fatina
poverina cervello di chi il piede di
girata orecchio abbiamo l'orecchio di
gigante ho paura di quello che potrebbe
succedere ma volevo di riuscire a farsi
ricrescere i capelli almeno ferro dice
di ingredienti dice pozione di ferro
proviamo a berla e vediamo
consiglio di fare mi sono cresciuti
megabus
nostra fa protesi ma è
lamentato quella che anche tutte vi
farete le pozioni dai ora fa una pozione
evitare
ok dobbiamo andare alla postazione di
vita e di una lezione di pozioni di
harry potter tranne che manca milito ne
sembra tutto così allegro ma realtà poi
diventi un mostro parte la tua
postazione non è questa senza forse
ancora treno cametti il calderone
calderoni d'oro finiamo i cui si
trasformerà antico napolitano autorizza
troppo questo non mi ricordo quale la
mia postazione
dove sei finito aspetta ma eccolo eccolo
è questa qui a fianco
ok sbriga allora dice che randy brecker
allora io prenderei il sandwich e lo
ammetto quadrante vomitare non poteva
non prendere il cibo vedi cosa succede
ma perché i miei muscoli che si muovono
hai bevuto aspetta lo sto ancora facendo
compagni mescolarla dove vado a prendere
baby teniamo video che cosa succederà
adesso
un sito che cosa è quello niente
quando cammini fieschi
no
ma posso mischiare due reporter ha
veramente la posizione perfetta per
votare continuando a sparare il pallino
fatto messo il cervello a 7 e la
funzione che rispecchia vitale vediamo
vediamo funzionare il cervello che cosa
succede adesso vediamo come si tratta o
no vedo molto
più devo preparare orrei una pozione per
salvarlo
aspetta vado subito nella mia postazione
proposta al bar si sono così vicino il
calderone
auguro quanti crediti che erano venuti
andare in giro a prendere gli
ingredienti noi invece ci siamo vecchi
amici a bere tutte le mozioni subito
guarda come ti amo credo come possono
suscitare adesso voglio a salvarli
vediamo che cosa posso darti proviamo
con la fatina poverina mi dispiace
sacrificarla per una operazione e non un
altro tempo insomma mi riprendo con la
sala ricerca dove ancora peggio è allora
la posso prendere non la voglio bere
aspetta voglio portarla a te aiuto se un
gigante po indietro che mi segue
io cercavo di trovarlo attiri la fazione
che come faccio a berlo adesso come
faccio ad artena ti vedo che sei qui
vicino però ecco drop qualcuno ha
lasciato una pozione qua non so che cosa
vasto mi avrebbero scattato lo problema
è la mozione che ha dato a ok qualcun
altro ci sto prendo una mozione per
salvarti penso ok tu sei ancora morta ma
io ho bevuto quella tua e sono diventato
il gigante premi la funzione di questo
ragazzo che volete al barman che lo sta
bevendo
ci siamo sono diventato invisibile che
succede che cosa ne pato è scappato il
cappotto arrivato blu
[Musica]
invita che provo a fare un'altra mozione
uso in europa gira male farmi tornare
normale per favore ti fidi di me
perché non c'è problema sede allora
vediamo o la pozione da gigante no
grazie sono abbastanza molto da voi come
vi faccio a tornare normale mi piace
perché ormai io guarda ti schiaccio
e io provo a fare qualche altra pozione
proviamo con la fatina andrà in porto ma
con camaleon e mettiamo anche questo
dietetici raffa io con camaleonte lo
puoi utilizzare la tua porzione non mi
fidavo hanno trovato più su un albero in
ambiti dall'aspetto buffo ma ho fatto
una pozione né era cosa succederà
vediamo allora io vado a fare una
pozione con il cavallo
no
non è diventato piccolissima ma fa male
più aggraziato fatto loro inferiorità o
la più piccola come la partita nelle
gambe piccoli schermi con le braccia
gigante voglio fare una pozione da
gigante forse per tornare come prima e
pamela pozione del gigante nuovo troppo
tardi ho appena fatto quello del
camaleonte e che cosa fa
ok la madre si fa per me è normale
allora vediamo è drop ok vai puoi
prendere ok la vediamo che cosa succede
allora possiamo devono tutto
[Musica]
a
luciano gigante con le braccia di
cameron ora il mio colore affetto cosa
mi avvicino
fantastica
se devo trovare il modo di fare una
pozione che mi faccio a tornare come
prima forse devo trovare altri
ingredienti io questo andando proprio
alla ricerca di altri ingredienti ho
un'idea prova a mettere tutti gli
ingredienti nel calderon galatone e
vediamo che bruxelles potrebbe essere un
disastro ma potrebbe anche farli tornare
come prima in realtà noi dovremo seguire
tutte le pozioni scritte nel libro ma
stiamo quasi mai ha scritto ho trovato
un ape che stava volando un personaggio
è andata a prenderla e tipo la punta ed
è caduto per terra vediamo cosa succede
se avevo questa pozione con tutti gli
ingredienti
ma tendente emesso
a che cosa successa è perso un braccio
che mostra è quello che sentivo bene
ma scherzate
nota trovato dire meter ok dammela
magari
già certo effetto letale tantissime cose
qui il fantastico quella di una vita va
bene perché scoraggia a meno che poi non
hai un fisico sto bevendo apportava
rimanere così lo prendo a portarti
ledere unite possono votare
ma c'è una mela ha come una mela che
bello sott'acqua ci sono degli
ingredienti
io non rispondo comunque prezzo giganti
ora ti lascio la dinamite poi proprio ok
quasi uno share e così quando tutti gli
ingredienti na scotti troppo divertente
però qual è la tua postazione salendo su
emendato postazione dopo aver
esplorato tutta questa mappa è
bellissima spero di riuscire a trovare
degli ingredienti rari
[Musica]
allora
è che mi sarà buttato
ma almeno sono tornate come prima nuovo
a roma è più una pozione del mio
calderone o meno che non avrò trovato
gli ingredienti allora ti sto facendo
una pozione proprio adatte ok che
possiede terra pregando poi la beve mi
dovrei imitare i militari e secondo
guarda mi hanno appena dato un coso qui
un riconoscimento ha commentato il
medaglione perché ho fatto questa
pozione fantastica
allora sono qui dietro di te no grazie
ma non sono sicuro se però potrà e
vitale onore programma
vediamo cosa succederà adesso
altro l'ufficialità
[Musica]
ok allora fate brother è proprio la mia
vita era la dinamite più la fatina
quindi dinamite fatina tifa cuore dei
soli roma proverà rahman ero io una
pulizia ma che serve a portare
gli intenti più male invece per vitale
sparito da noemi a questo ingrediente ok
non riesce a prender ma venderla prova a
prendere questo alveare di api allora o
no
andiamo a metterlo nel calderone che
società ho creato una pozione che il
nome è fantastico e come nome
tra voglio prima offrire fino allora io
una mozione per te e tu bevi la mia
posizione io verrò la tua potere fema da
ho provato nella mia mozione devi prima
tu la tua devi vediamo
ma è bellissimo
fare a papa pio vi posso dire no
no no no no no no no no allontanati noi
ala d'oro questa ma questo che ti ho
fatto una bella posizione spero che
anche la tua siano bella porzione
vediamo sì
[Musica]
c'era scritto
la scritta scoreggia nucleare
[Risate]
no non credo
dopo i vari fatti analizzare non troppo
di vento carico familiare
proprietà le come stiamo e semplice per
fido e andiamo aprendo loro che altri
crediti pro roma letti non ho ben capito
come funziona a guidare sfilare con le
ali a spostarsi con le fasi di gara 1
spero che rimarrei un'ape per tempo
prende con sé essendo ha provato
sott'acqua non muoio però guardo questo
porta posso volare anche sott'acqua come
a per
terremoto qualcosa ma non
capirli una parrucca
non ci credo che sei sott'acqua come
un'ape
po difficile per volare come tranquilla
si sta preparando una porzione perfetta
per me ok mettiamo anche il parrucchino
non so se aggiungere qualcos'altro
[Musica]
dai vieni qua un orto fai sempre le
pozioni nero tanto perché vestita nera
anche questa che allora più per te è
adesso vedrete ottimizzare
noi stiamo che sono un locale capiti mai
ora uno zombie scoreggia a fare a botte
di chiamate solo tu puoi fare queste
botteghe ben
22 volte la mia mozione ops qualcuno
ecco
l'attesa era piaciuta questa è diventato
minuscolo
mi volevi far diventare minuscolo avevo
nemmeno che avrebbe fatto
cadevi togliere gli ingredienti hai
capito in base agli ingredienti che
emette io per esempio ho tolto al
nucleare prima però lasciato scoreggia
fi ora devo continuare come uno zombie
abbiamo subito qualcosa per dettagli
vediamo se sott'acqua c'è qualcosa devo
assolutamente trasformarlo in modo non è
giusto che non hai bevuto stata vi ho
ripreso il parrucchino torniamo al
calderone mettiamo il parrucchino anche
se non so cosa faccia comunque penso che
più tempo giochi a questo gioco più
diversi bravo nelle pozioni capitolino
non è niente che cosa fa dalle continue
rabbit dell'ingrediente scoreggia
ovviamente il ragno vado a prenderlo un
fatto
ho fatto una pozione rossa questa volta
vediamo come si chiama ma perfetto io
non mi fido più bene le sue posizioni
prima devo preparare una mozione per the
ok io ho preparato la pozione rossa per
terre d'acqua puoi mettere la posizione
spararla col cannone wow e c'è la scopo
di una stretta una strega sembra no e
perché è un buco è caduta dentro la
sabbia che questo nota via mobili armi
meno scontato quindi forse c'è anche la
pozione per trasformarsi il premio
infatti c'è un'altra bufala dop e stai
domandando non lo trova e bellissimo
attesa e knock you down italia star a
gila un'altra strega dispiace accennava
confortanti
ho preso la testa di una scimmia
se questa foto
è
stato il vero che posso parlarci qui tar
si possono fare delle emozioni diverse
ogni sera i utile sprechi e forse ti
regalano qualcosa però prima devo
completare la pozione per pietà e se
allora io certo affronta d'arte
e allora dove sei
allora vieni qua nella mia postazione
altrimenti qualcun altro sì ruberà la
forma con cui questa volta devi prima tu
no no no perché io pero sono più
originale è fatta di colori diversi no
io ho bevuto prima
grossa ai baby dai insieme
123 vai
perché non hai bevuto beni subito ho
voluto è successo niente
[Musica]
più guarita hai visto non sei più zombie
si sono che aspetta vissuto los formando
piano piano che succede sì perché c'era
il colore del camaleonte ho fatto una
pozione contiamo quattro ingredienti
c'era il cervello colore e scoreggia e
comune che senti sono le scorre senza
rumore beh ora bevi tu
che cosa mi succede ma
ha negato un costume meraviglioso una
scimmia a me con la testa al contrario
con la
brillantezza come l'hanno
creato un mostro
9 questo è bellissimo che sposi la tengo
bene ora facciamo l'ultima porzione
molto parla degli ingredienti
particolari l'ultima porzione e voi
dovrete votare nei commenti se vinco io
se vince è vitale in base alla
trasformazione più bella di quest'ultima
dobbiamo impegnarci
ora cerco di ingredienti milioni allora
tolgo la scorreggia per questa volta
questo treno mi ha scritto che si sono
spiaccicate stavano volando con le
tolgono
spiaccicate keko perché c'erano quei
segni la poi dice che devono tornare a
casa i conti possa aiutare dobbiamo fare
una posizione ok no adesso non posso
aiutare le streghe magari nel prossimo
episodio adesso devo creare una pozione
magica
io ho un posto segreto dove trovare gli
ingredienti
o qualcuno non è riuscito a fare la
mozione per vitale beh almeno sono
tornata normale però dello strumento a
trovare degli ingredienti allora io ho
trovato già un ingrediente che non ho
ancora utilizzati ma cos'è la rana però
adesso devo trovare un ingrediente nuovo
tale mi voleva in una rana dove trovare
qualcosa di più gigante devo vincere ho
trovato questo posto dove ci sono tanti
ingredienti dove mi trovo
non so più cosa sia costi ingrediente
mettiamolo nel calderone anche se non so
cosa sia anche la mia mozione è quasi
pronta devo sbrigarmi ei che questa
tarda a prendere degli ingredienti e tu
ma non come leoni per leonte sappiamo
già che ferrara possa cambiare colore
mai avuto qualcosa di te gigante vitali
ha detto che ha trovato un posto in cui
trova tanti ingredienti quindi seguita
da
mi viene che cos'è quello non lo so
è lei scalciato non l'ho fatto apposta
ehi ma cosa hai preso non mi dire che
hai preso la dinamite
ritrovabile
quello trasformiamo in un uccellino
oppure in un pesce
poi l'uranio
città c'è qualcos'altro qua dei fagioli
questi parola volontà così scoreggia
ok mettiamo solite ragioni io ho fatto
la pozione e poi come ultimo ingrediente
prendo che questo non lo posso dire a
voce alta novità le sente ma prendo lo
vedete voi sa che cosa stesse gergo io
vado a prendere altri ingredienti per la
pasta
è pronta la mia mozione
ok sfida finale in cui voi dovrete
votare chi ha fatto la figlia del potere
la migliore trasformazione per la sfida
finale andremo quando di formattare la
vedranno tutti francano di fano quindi
seguite yec sicura guarda io ho una
pozione colorata prende la sua mozione
al mio tre
dobbiamo berla va bene uno due tre
che cosa di trasformarlo
in
un girino di fuoco
capito se tu non so chi la pozione si ti
da tutti gli ingredienti che li messo
prima
per questo tu sei una poi una scimmia e
io sono morta invece la formazione l'ho
fatta con una rana la dinamite e il
peperoncino
poi è stata la migliore trasformazione
secondo voi scrivete nei commenti la
prossima volta mi ricorderò di svuotare
il primo il cambio solito e poi la
cuffia se volete una seconda forte forse
il solito la costa sono giusto quattro
castellini scrivi carmelo dei nostri
altri video cliccate su quella che
preferite buona visione